le cocktail sans alcool c'est une balle
c'est une bonne idée alors je voulais
vous parler du projet en fait il ça a
cartonné quand on a fait le matin le
soir et 35 heures est en fait une région
luc et toi en animateur taintrux castro
donc l'horoscope ensuite tac tout à une
rubrique people as trouve que j'ai bien
vidéo
après bon il ya un invité et ensuite
voilà derrière tu vois c'est un peu des
astuces eu tout ça du système dé pouce à
ces chaleurs champignons or c'est
délicieux les attaques du championnat et
il y en aura 6 mais moi je suis en fait
moi il m'a mis du poulet est ce que je
voulais que les champignons c'est moi je
mange pas bien je pense pas que ça va
toucher on peut manger choque pas durant
alors tu étudies l'émission sur
l'émission beaucoup des champignons tu
voudrais faire ou pas si on le fait à la
rentrée
moi ça m'intéresse moi sincèrement je
pense que le monde m'attend pas
le report d'un mois mais non mais sinon
mais c'est un devoir c'est le conte a
choisi surtout je pense vraiment que le
monde attend qui que ce soit des
créations très épicée vous devez
confondre excusez moi mais je connais
mais c'est mon meilleur ami effet c'est
sur sa corde excusez là monsieur non
mais c'est madame emma green confiance
excusez moi travailler at elle est
appréciée qui me compliquer c'est ton
meilleur ami nuit à lui s'est excusé moi
vous appelez françois ou pas du tout non
ce n'est pas lui mais c'est vrai qu'il a
une balle rapide succès à françois oui
c'est pas lui
c'est pas lui alors mes chers mais
attends moi je le connais pas ce gars là
mercredi ils jouent avec moi sur la
connexion avec la je connais pas je vous
connais pas tous la même en bresse où je
me sentais bizarre juste que j'allais
essayer d'avoir des constructeurs
connaissent pas que morales
maintenant jean luc tavernier médias qui
était comme la famille de pension et des
déserteurs mais sans déconner tu veux
pas l'impôt toilettes tout son visage
mais je trouve bizarre dans les airs et
un peu pas franchement dans un pop up